before this video begins I just want to
thank you guys so much for 66 million
subscribers it really means a lot to me
that you guys are still subscribing and
showing your support
[Music]
desperate times calls for desperate
measure means if we beat t-series I will
bring back bonus me that's right can't
let the Indians beat us did I just lose
three subscribers
oh thanks going backwards as in
treasonous a'ready crows and now maybe
we should sing a nice episode of why
hello everybody welcome back to another
week of what is my wife's painful sex no
I'm just kidding it stands for last week
I asked you it's an original concept
that I came up with myself basically I
asked you guys to do something and next
we got review it and that means just
took over the whole reddit cuz that's
what everyone do we just upload it
anyway but I thought let's make the why
Lawai again okay so I have a new
challenge for you guys yeah I can see
you I can see you so last week I asked
you guys to design my aim controller
comm custom controller which will be the
official PD PI control this is not just
any custom controller all right you got
lifetime warranty so when you have those
epic rage gamer moment we got you
covered
actually I don't know if it covers that
at all I just felt like that would be a
nice they got smart triggers all right
you'll be the fastest one there's a
shortened pressure point in these babies
so you'll have faster reaction time then
your enemies you'll be the most epic
gamer of all time basically with this
controller Erica no make back paddles
that's right so you can hold this baby
for hours without hurting your finger it
also has a mistakes we should lazy to
change to hike the top all that good
stuff and different colors now let's
look at the winner
the official pity PI controller goes to
creeper ninja this one one by far 22,000
up buds damn a very nice with this
controller you'll have zero depth
guarantee baby I love it it's so cool
and you took the classic PewDiePie meme
and you made it almost better
congratulations creeper ninja I want to
give you the very first copy of it
signed and I won't sign any other so
hopefully there's some exclusivity that
I
thanks to everyone for submitting I'll
go through some more later as well I
thought that check out the link
description to get your exclusive aim
controller down there baby
alright let's get into the memes what
have you guys posted
I made him chuckle the cycle continues
god dammit
are you kidding me this is the dumbest
thing I have ever seen in my life
there's nothing to pride here how many
times has I been one two now unboxing
the 399 chair wait some what you got the
chair legend look what I found
[Music]
No
that can't be right
that cannot be right t-series is working
with my chair
[Music]
has changed he secretly owns t-series
it's obvious world war three
who do you think is gonna win this
battle if you see this I hope you like
it
alright that is cool actually that's
very nice
I love that what Donnell's a Mac from
outfit as well that's super do I'll be
wearing this for my final battle against
t-series I have been training
oh that's epic okay alright that's that
big alright so if everyone does this
then we don't have to worry about it
mad line wipe sixty million people off
the earth found this on Twitter she
wants peers to know this let him see it
can someone please help me tweet
PewDiePie and tell him that he's in my
Mass Communication text books for
calling this is so weird
this is the second time someone told me
about me being in like an actual school
book someone else said what I mean like
a sociology study or something du shell
Berg is the most famous person on the
planet you've never heard of what at
least if you're older than 40 and don't
have young people in the house okay
unless you're nine years old this you
could have just said that
don't let him forget
there's a boo music cover Oh me myself
get that for our wedding that's
beautiful stop holding me accountable
for my promises and it's a pretty tune I
feel like I could get away with it dude
what if hold it hold on for a second
what if I bought t-series and deleted it
this is so epic spent 25 years making
this incredible I'm so proud to have
fans that really take the time and
dedication to show their support
25 years sex that's a lot of nine years
let me guess
your bike it was but I thought okay damn
it I missed the bike meme that was the
frick and remember that that was the
first meme review the thing that started
it all the bike cook can we appreciate
that this was posted on our anniversary
one year one year without dropping me on
board thank you guys yeah look inspector
it's nothing more celebrating please
stop when you made into intellectual
video by living in a simulation but you
your subscribers want you to play Lego
Star Wars does anyone actually want me
to play Lego Star Wars if this video
gets 500 million thousand likes is that
too many if this video gets 400,000
likes I will play Lego Star Wars okay
it's a main design so it has chances to
win the comfort
I mean yeah that's pretty clever
actually that's really good their rule
is simple you lay you loose just do it
Wow thank you Nike for the millions of
millions of dollars that I was paid for
my giant sacrifice imagine if I stopped
doing YouTube and then this company paid
me millions and millions and everyone be
like what a sacrifice what a hero
review the mean even if it means
sacrificing see why don't I where's my
Nike deal you know control the
submission plus merch plus channel Cour
damn taking the extra mile by sinister
Bulgaria these are very cool actually
the shirt is though I like it I do
really like making it myself although I
do appreciate you guys submissions of
like banners and stuff like that
I do like designing those kind of stuff
myself it makes it more personal all
right how long do you guys think that
Thanos car mean will be popular please
place your bets in the comments right
now the winner will win Lego playthrough
I'll invite you bros to my wedding how
about that stop stop holding how many
prophecies have I made okay first up if
we beat t-series I will invite you okay
how's that
smash subscribe
[Music]
wow that's so nice to see another
nine-year-old played the theme that I
composed my very self thank you very
much the most trusted me that's sick I
like that actually my entry for the
controller company that's sake I like
that actually
okay so for next week of Lawai I'm gonna
leave a download link for a bunch of
photos since you guys like relatable
pictures where you can go that's me
I'm gonna do you guys a favor of adding
a bunch of reaction faces that you can
put in your favorite meme everybody the
best ones will of ready to review next
week Lavoie thank you guys so much for
watching and all the support honestly
I'm so lucky to have you guys
my favorite 9 gurus thanks for watching
this video guys and thanks Jenny
patrollers for sponsoring it it's a very
cool product I think you guys are gonna
like it
link in the description bye
[Music]